[Musique]
un nouveau fait a ajouté au chapitre des
soucoupes volantes un cultivateur de
moringhem monsieur daniel you a été le
témoin stupéfait mais observateurs de la
présence d'un de ces engins que les
scientifiques appellent duterne de
compromettant d'objets volants non
identifiés
voici la déclaration que ce nouveau
témoin a bien voulu nous faire payer on
allait manger si mes beaux-parents et en
rentrant le soir on a abaissé sur la
route comme une boule rouge qui arrivait
sur new d'arriver sur la droite et dans
un virage nous a coupé la route et d'adp
est parti sur la gauche
alors on a dû freiner brusquement pour
le vitib parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
passer en dessous le tout le monde passe
et basse et après nous ont suivis comme
ça vous serez 100 m à 4 m de nous sur la
gauche vous avez nettement l'impression
d'avoir été observée par cet ange alors
un peu benêt qu'en matière de services
mais c'est bizarre qu'elle vient de se
passer pour notre voiture et quelle
forme avait-il en dessous c'était une
boule rouge est au dessus il y avait une
masse ne peut pas distinguer ce que
c'est parce qu on est ébloui basse rouge
à cette blouse rouge se paieront cela et
c'était comme un soleil c'était roméo
dessus peut pas d'excès père ont souvent
l'impression que c'était télécommandées
ou qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui pilotait
on peut dire qu'ils avaient quelques
dents contre certainement ce que je vous
dis havel et l'arbre et est passé en
deux alors certainement qui voyait clair
si tu doutes ou quoi
toujours est il que depuis cette
rencontre les vaches refusent leur
nourriture
les chiens sont fébriles y at il parmi
nous comme certains le prétendent des
présence d'un visite
c'est donc ici le voir dans ces petites
routes que la dizaine de témoins a pu
observer le phénomène alors comment ça
s'est passé
on le vit ensemble en même temps
exactement en même temps et en même
temps une double exclamations mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cela qu'est ce
que c'est que cela j'ai vu ce gros
machin qui était comme ça on aurait dit
derrière c'était des pattes d'araignée
alors ça dégageait compte du gaz et des
machines papier qu'il souhaitait
derrière et j'étais absolument hypnotisé
par cet objet insolite
lorsque siemens ne prend pas loin de 10
je regarde ce qu'il ya là bas nous avons
regardé alors là franchement nous avons
eu peur l'un et l'autre mais vraiment
peur car les trois objets qui apparaît
c'est à l'horizon était en tout point
semblable au premier
ils sont venus à peu près opinion dans
l'axé pignon oui c'est cela
norris qui les amuse et il s'amusait
ensemble alors des mouvements symétrique
verticales horizontales verticales
horizontales quel est le bruit que vous
avez entendu est ce que c'est un
sifflement ça comme un grincement vas-y
que je te pousse
lorsqu'au moment précis où il semblait
que tout allait s'effondrer au milieu
d'un choc effroyable le premier objet
monter en altitude et la première fois
brièvement bénaissa il est monté avec
une vitesse extraordinaire j'estime à
plus de deux milles à l'heure au bout
d'un moment on n'a plus vu qu'un seul
petit point noir et j'ai dit à chimène
cette fois ça y est le spectacle est
terminé et vous avez désormais un prénom
ans avocate vous non pas des drogues en
a bien quelques dizaines à une
désillusion dans le ciel on ne peut pas
parler d'hallucinations
en 1917 a été créé un groupe d'étude des
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
qui travaille donc à l'exploitation des
témoignages c'était le 5 février 1967 à
21h45 de soual je ferme la clé alors que
j'ai même appelé ma poche que d'un coup
qu'est ce que je vois un appareil qui
est un objet qui passe par dessus le
cimetière on voyait les tombes aussi
bien éclairées quant plage où justement
est-ce qu'ils riaient les conseils à
donner aux témoins éventuels
eh bien je pense que le mieux serait de
leur fixer un peu la conduite à tenir
il convient donc d'attirer si possible
l'attention d'autres témoins j'appelle
la patronne j'ai dit il vient vite
didier vite voilà bien vite voire de la
marque de danger en cas de danger je
suis peu jeudi sera plus de la maison et
nous avec
je suis sauvé de la cuisine est
physiquement plus ils donnent été
soigneusement et le plus tôt possible
la forme les dimensions apparente et la
couleur du phénomène on a vu une boule
simplement qu'ils se reformer il est
sorti des flammes rouges tels que
l'objet lui même semble lui sans rien du
tout tout d'un coup il s'est posé aparté
qu'est ce que je vois un petit bonhomme
qui sortait des flammes orange épicière
tourner ici retourné vers moi j'aimais
mieux vous dire franchement comme un
corps et un petit cosmonaute quoi mais
tout petit s'il avait eu mais d'auteur
c'est tout ce que c'est tout ce qui peut
avoir je vous demanderais de ne pas
avoir peur du ridicule
êtes-vous confiant que les
renseignements donnés seront oubliées
terme en exploité par les équipes
spécialisées
[Musique]
en belgique la chasse aux ovnis est
ouverte de la banlieue de bruxelles à la
frontière allemande
le ciel va être passée au peigne fin
durant tout le week-end en tout vingt
postes fixes d'observation six équipes
mobiles deux avions de l'armée belge
équipés de caméras infrarouges sans
compter les dizaines de scientifiques et
leur matériel ultra perfectionnés et si
les autorités ont déployé une telle
armada c'est que dans la nuit du 30 au
31 mars quelque chose d'étrange ses
produits
nous avons envoyé deux avions et
finalement les pilotes n'ont rien
constaté
visuellement mais ils ont quand même
fait de détection radar
voici cette fameuse image radar
enregistré par deux avions f 16 au sud
de bruxelles
l'intrus s'est se loge dans ge lumineux
au centre de l'écran on ralentit on
observe la trajectoire de l'objet en
trois secondes seulement l'ovni plonge
de 4 1000 à 1500 mètres d'altitude
l'accélération a été fulgurante 2000 à
1900 kilomètres heure il y a eu des
accélérations d'un orgue de tempe 40g et
sept exclus ne connaisse cumin supporter
des accélérations paris pour en avoir le
coeur net tout le monde a été mis sur le
pont ainsi jusqu'à mardi matin les
brigades de gendarmerie seront en alerte
pour recevoir les appels de la
population parmi eux marcel al far à nos
un habitant de bruit celle qui a eu le
réflexe de films et quand l'opération
sera terminée on en saura peut être plus
sur la forme les dimensions et l'énergie
utilisée pour propulser cet engin
bizarre un engin qui en tout cas aura
fait tourner la tête à plus d'un belge
les ovnis ces fameux objets volants non
identifiés sont revenus en force
la séparation entre la science et
l'irrationnel devient moins précise et
parfois même l'imagination l'emportent
sur la certitude depuis des millénaires
c est reviennent sur la terre on pense
que nous sommes nous les terriens le
résultat d'une de leurs expériences
alors dans un autre ils viennent voir où
nous en sommes et il existe des milliers
de témoignages de l'atterrissage de ces
engins ils sont deux à s'être approché
de cette barrière
patrick 21 ans profondément choqué ne
veut plus voir personne
c'est dans l'anonymat qu'il a accepté de
raconter ce qu'il a vu arriver à
quelques centaines de mètres de
l'endroit où voyons l'objet le moteur
s'est arrêté des phares ma radio qui
était allumée cette étape 100 raisons de
vendre sans raison apparente
l'objet qui a atterri induit une
modification du champ magnétique locales
et santé - canular ne peut pas inventer
un truc pareil nous avions l'impression
que c'était un anneau un anneau qui qui
tourner lentement et de sa s'est détaché
un cône une forme de quartier de tarte
et ensuite l'objet a disparu
complètement l'objet à avant de
disparaître à arrêter dossier sur lui
même mais très rapidement
ce n'était plus qu'à un point en ciel il
sur la possibilité de passer d'un
univers à la glace comme exactement en
tant qu il alors ça il faut le prouver
bien sûr mais je pense que ça appartient
où la génération qui vient je dépose
générations futures car nous accrochons
peu à peu de la vérité
ce récit pourrait être
science fiction c'est pourtant une
histoire vraie je suis tout chez nous là
dessus de maple est habile été précédée
noir iron sea d'andré de coccinelles des
groupes
oui et tenero quatre personnes d'une
même famille ont vu l'objet de très près
se stabiliser au dessus du cerisier du
jardin voisin
ce qui m'a beaucoup impressionné moi
c'est ses grosses pattes grise
métallique qui se trouve à l'extrémité
de cet appareil et cette lumière rouge
qui faisait le tour j'ai immédiatement
la famille prévient les gendarmes dans
la demi-heure deux brigadiers récoltent
leurs témoignages comme le prévoit la
procédure dans les cas de détection
d'ovni le témoin a dessiné ce qui lui
semble être la dimension de cet objet au
dessus de au dessus de l'arbre et en
voit très bien sur son dessin des formes
un peu bizarre de
en fait de l'ovni qui était qui était
observé dans le cas de voreppe
la solution est apparue au bout d'une
semaine quand la presse s'est emparée de
la sphère faisant affluer les
témoignages parmi les gens qui sont
venus me trouver donc il y avait un
couple qui nous a fait savoir que ou à
ce jour là cette heure-là non un du lieu
donc où il était venu à venir il avait
perdu un ballon gonflé à l'hélium en
forme de coccinelle l'histoire du ballon
peut pas être impossible kendall on a vu
ce qu'on a vu on peut pas croire ballon
ballon mais je pensais que c'est quoi un
objet volant non identifié depuis plus
de dix ans de mystérieux cercle
apparaissent chaque été dans les champs
de blé
toujours dans le kent une région située
au sud est de londres
les scientifiques ont observé
attentivement ce phénomène qui selon eux
serait paranormal en juin dernier les
japonais se sont installés plusieurs
jours avec du matériel sophistiqué
message d'extra terrestres ou phénomènes
naturels
les chercheurs avaient tous une bonne
explication
aujourd'hui un quotidien populaire
britannique today prétend révéler la
main coupable deux alerte sexagénaire
qui seraient les auteurs du canular
il aurait pété cet après midi leurs
techniques méthodes simples et archaïque
une ficelle reliés aux deux extrémités
d'un bâton et après avoir soigneusement
dessiné les plans dès la nuit tombée ils
écrasaient soigneusement les blés et
aujourd'hui ils jouent les artistes
quand on en a eu assez de faire des
cercles bien nous avons décidé
d'améliorer notre technique de travail
est aujourd'hui plutôt réussi mais le
mystère n'est pas totalement éclaircies
des scientifiques de renom se sont
rendus sur place et ont constaté
l'apparition mystérieuse de ces cercles
et si ces deux hommes n'étaient pas de
gentils farceur
[Musique]
dans ces cieux troubler un point
lumineux mais ce n'est pas un point
d'espoir c'est un point lumineux et
mystérieux voilà que l'on reparle des
ovni au vernis à ongles et volants
non-identifiés populairement les
soucoupes volantes si vous préférez un
phénomène lumineux une sorte de triangle
dans le ciel de provence une nuée
blanche avec 1.1 rosa son centre pour
les gens d'angoulême une sorte
d'embrasement solaire en catalogne
enfin pour les spécialistes en réalité
il pourrait s'agir d'une sonde spatiale
qui aurait explosé avant de tomber ou
bien d'une capsule scientifiques lancés
du centre d'essais des landes et le
panache de gaz
éclairé par le soleil aurait dégagé la
combustion du troisième étage d'une
fusée ayant servi à l'expérience c'est
ce que l'on dit tout au moins à l'onera
qui responsable de l'expérience mais
vous imaginez bien que pour les
soucoupistes ce n'est pas du tout le cas
les soucoupistes attentif à toutes les
manifestations de ces phénomènes il
pourrait s'agir d'autre chose et
soucoupistes ils sont 500 en france à
peu près à observer le ciel a enquêté
à noter les moindres indices ils sont
500 comme ce monsieur lagarde que
christian paul de passe a rencontré dans
le massif central monsieur lagarde
observateurs enquêteurs pour le centre
d'étude baptisé centre d'études lumière
dans la nuit on les forme des ovnis sont
extrêmement diverses
le type classique c'est la soucoupe
volante en forme l'assiette à renverser
le cigare qui avale incliné à 22 le
réseau l'horizontale le ballon de rugby
la forme discoïdales la forme d'obus la
boule lumineuse
tous ces objets sont divers et nombreux
yatela ya également le satellite
l'observé satellites dont à vue à
narbonne avionneurs soudain qu'on a vu
en belgique qu'on a vu à megève
c'est un objet rond autour desquels
tournent des satellites plus ou moins
nombreux de 2 à 6
il ya également tous les jeux de lumière
dans suspens sont susceptibles ces
engins
des voeux des feux multicolores de
toutes les couleurs mais les formes de
ces engins secondi fille devant les
témoins même dans les charentes
on a vu un objet qui a pris
successivement six formes différentes et
de vingt six témoins
[Musique]
voici l'appareil qui sert à détecter les
objets volants non identifiés
il est basé sur les variations du champ
magnétique terrestre
les compose d'une barre aimante et qui
doit bien être orientée nord-sud d'une
pile qui met en contact le ronfleur
d'une perle mémoire qui soumet avec les
vibrations du ronfleur descend le long
de sa tige
lorsque nous allons simuler une
apparition d'objets volants non
identifiés en approchant un aimant et la
perle dessin lambda tiges dont ils
étaient dix neuf heures environ et je
sortais de ma voiture et je regarde dans
le sial et qu'est ce que je vois j'ai
l'impression que c'était des avions qui
est en manoeuvre donc il est temps en
triangle et ce qui m'étonnait pourtant
c'est que j'ai entendu aucun bruit dont
je me suis dit ou alors ils vont la très
haute altitude
alors je les verrai pas donc ça ne
paraissait pas logique et après je suis
l'on acceptait de daisy town finances
mais comme il y en avait presque une
dizaine de disques nationale j'ai fait
un peu et puis je me suis dit on verra
bien j'ai pensé d'abord qu'il s'agissait
effectivement de fusées de nouvel an de
choses de ce genre qui était lancé m'a
ensuite que geny com j'ai vu que ça se
dirigeait donc vers le zénith c'était
oui j'étais relativement surpris lien
c'était un spectacle relativement très
très beau voilà ce que tout ce que je me
faisais penser à des ovnis non j'ai
reçus à partir de 19h10 quelques coups
de téléphone de personnes appelant de
différents villages avoisinants me
demandant si j'étais si j'avais
connaissance
d'un phénomène bizarre verticale ces
personnes signalé avoir vu un objet
lumineux qui passait dans le ciel un
objet de forme ronde assez important qui
se déplaçait lentement de l'ouest vers
l'est avec une gerbe d'étincelles à
l'arrière même si les radars n'ont rien
détecté c'est désormais sur le ciel de
strasbourg a été hier soir le théâtre
d'un phénomène insolite une apparition
de quelques instants qui devrait trouver
une explication naturelle peut être par
la présence de nombreux satellites
c'est tout à fait plausible que à un des
nombreux satellites sont décomposées que
un morceau ce soit décomposé en
plusieurs parcelles et que nous ayons vu
ça ou bien une autre explication
peut-être y at-il eu un météorite à
cépet assez gros qui serait qui se
serait désintégré assez bas déjà dans la
peau sphère badin très haute atmosphère
et là aussi les différents morceaux du
les compositions que nous aurions pu
voir peut-être dès aujourd'hui
l'observatoire de munich confirment
l'hypothèse d'une météorite qui aurait
explosé en entrant dans l'atmosphère
quant au centre national d'études
spatiales il n'a pas encore donné ses
conclusions
ce total le cnes le centre national
d'études spatiales met en ligne ses
archives sur les ovnis et son site
internet a été presque aussi tous
saturés par les requêtes d'internautes
férus ou pas de phénomènes inexpliqués
c'est le dossier de ce 19 ans patrick
esther il garde une lumière bizarre dans
ciel nocturne
cela ressemble souvent à cela ne veut ni
parfois c'est une mystérieuse soucoupe
volante
ici il s'agit en fait d'un lampadaire de
jardin mais les plaisanteries de ce
genre restent rares
le centre spatial de toulouse conserve
les archives de 6000 témoignages
concernant 1650 cas d'observation placé
sous la responsabilité de l'ingénieur
jacques patenée des cartes des objets
des procès verbaux
1971 un pilote de mirage poursuivi par
un avenir janvier 80 une soucoupe
métallique se pose dans un jardin à
trans-en-provence laissant des traces au
sol janvier 94
l'airbus d'air france croise un
gigantesque disque
jusqu'ici seuls quelques privilégiés
avaient accès à ces procès verbaux de
gendarmerie et à ces documents
confidentiels du cnes désormais d'un
seul clic de souris
chacun pourra se faire sa propre idée
sur les ovni en visitant le site
internet du centre national d'études
spatiales
cette mise en ligne est destinée à
mettre fin au mythe du complot
une nécessité suite aux nombreuses
critiques essuyées par le cnes plusieurs
fois le service chargé d'étudier ces
phénomènes avait été réorganisées mais
la consigne de silence était resté
aujourd'hui le tiers des cas restent
inexpliquées comme cette histoire
survenue à sierre ce en haute garonne
durant une série de phénomènes en 54 un
homme circulait avec sa charrette à
cheval
son meilleur ami raconte ici surgi d'un
buisson un objet qu'ils assimilent
immédiatement une lessiveuse qui s'élève
du buisson qui se plomber la cayolle
qu'à ce moment là qui attire qui inspire
le la jument puis qui sait qui c'est ban
qui disparaît dans le ciel et et guy guy
has more like est sidéré il est paralysé
lauper l'observation et le témoignage de
siers s'insère parfaitement dans cette
notion de vagues et en particulier en
1954 où durant un mois un mois et demi
la france a été l'objet d'observations
de
nature tout à fait insolite d'objets
rapproché avec lesquels parfois des gens
voyaient des personnages ingénieur
aérospatial jean-jacques velasco a été
responsable du service du cnes durant
trente ans il a pu consulter
trente mille documents américains
déclassifiés comme cette affaire
concernant un site atomique survolé par
un engin le radar d'un b52 avait pu
enregistrer sa trace la conclusion les
performances aéronautique détecter
notamment par les radars en terme de
vitesse d'accélération de trajectoire
semble incompatible avec les aéronefs
les objets que nous serions capables de
concevoir et fabriquer ce qui veut dire
que si nous ne sommes pas capables
aujourd'hui de réaliser de tels objets
c'est qu'ils sont fabriqués par
quelqu'un d'autre qui viennent
d'ailleurs
d'où le fait que l'hypothèse
extraterrestre semble la plus plausible
claude poher le premier directeur du
service en 1977 avait dû démissionner
lui aussi est convaincu que le phénomène
est d'ampleur considérable le comprendre
nécessitera selon lui d' inventer une
science physique entièrement nouvelle
vous pouvez
ce n'est pas un canular moi je peux dire
que c'est pas un canular
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce jeudi
là à 17 heures précisément il s'est
passé rien de bien à l'origine rien de
bien extraordinaire c'est à dire qu'on
était ici on faisait une séquence sur le
bord du lac pour l'émission les étoiles
dans ce pli et puis j'ai fait un plan de
d'illustration un plan b est un peu
cartes postales du lac les fonds il est
sombre il était 5 heures du soir dont
j'ai fait mon plan il y avait rien de
spécial ya pas de comédie intérieur du
plan les gens c'était un peu dispersés
autour l'attend dès que j'ai fini
et puis au milieu du plan j'ai vu
quelque chose dans le huit ans alors
j'ai vu quelque chose de très imprécis
et sa gelée gel des communiqués à paris
c'est que le phénomène à l'oeil et dans
l'oeilleton était beaucoup moins visible
que sur la pellicule
quand on a reçu la pellicule cinq ou six
jours après j'étais très surpris de voir
que est ce que ça faisait du bruit c'est
non pas du tout il ya un certain nombre
de ces petits qu'aujourd'hui vous donner
leurs arguments pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
suivi l'objet ah oui alors ça c'est
cette question qui peut paraître
évidente
j'ai pas suivi l'objet d'abord parce que
ça s'est passé très vite
j'étais en cadre fixe la caméra était
bloqué ça c'est peut-être un manque de
réflexe on m'a demandé pourquoi on ne
voyait pas le reflet du phénomène dans
le lac
il ya trois possibilités le reflet est
masqué par la colline qui à côté du lac
ou alors la portion site de ciel
réfléter n'est pas du tout celle qu'on
voit dans le lac
c'est tout simple c'est la géométrie ou
alors la lumière émise par le phénomène
est polarisée et après réflexion sur le
sur le lac hylia extinction si la
polarisation est à 90 degrés c'est un
problème de physique sympa enfin est ce
que c'est possible de faire un truc à te
fabriquer je vous demande de faire ça de
faire un trucage identique est ce qu est
ce qu on a filmé je pensais
je pense qu'une simple surimpression
pourrait faire la fin mais ça se verrait
je devrais peut-être alors
premier type cloud simple phénomène
naturel en tout cas des centaines et des
centaines de témoignages pour décrire
hier le même phénomène un drôle de
triangle lumineux qui a traversé un peu
après 19 heures une bonne partie de la
france et une autre partie de l'europe
les spécialistes ont tenté depuis ce
matin d'expliquer cette apparition
c'est dominique dumas qui a enquêté sur
cet objet volant non identifié comme sur
ce document on aurait voulu y croire
une formation triangulaire lumineuse
semblable à un gigantesque cerf-volant
était observé par des dizaines de
personnes
hier vers 19 heures des témoignages
enregistrés à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de distance en bretagne en
région parisienne dans le sud-ouest de
la france sur la riviera italienne et en
alsace ma voiture et je regarde dans le
seul et qu'est ce que je vois j'ai
l'impression que c'était des avions qui
est en manoeuvre donc il était en
triangle et ce qui m'étonnait pourtant
c'est que j'ai entendu aucun bruit donc
je me suis dit ou alors ils volent à
très haute altitude alors je les verrai
pas donc ça ne paraissait pas logique et
après une si longue à se mettre des
étoiles filantes mais combien n'avait
pas ce qu'une visage me disent quand
même assez exceptionnel
j'ai fais un voeu et puis nous figurons
verra bien suite à ces informations je
me suis renseigné au centre de contrôle
civil de reims qui lui m'a fait savoir
que quelques pilotes avaient signalé des
phénomènes bizarres mais j'ai pas eu
plus de détails hélas pour les amateurs
de soucoupe l'observatoire de munich
vient d'annoncer qu'il s'agirait de
météores déjà à paris l'aviation civile
ce matin étaient sceptiques pensant
aussi à des débris de satellite ou à des
météorites
tant pis pour les petits hommes verts
toujours attendu sur la planète bleue
c'est comme ça quoi
oui c'était bien visible même sourit un
moment tu savais pas ce qui se passe est
quoi ce que pourrait bien semer de
l'ombre à goûter en discute que c'est
que ça emmanuel permis journée même pas
fait attention bureau de la mode support
musée du foie un coup de tonnerre c'est
bien c'est pas que la plainte avait
quelque chose d'anormal là le c pour ça
ce qu'on était un jeune a mis sur liste
quoi oui bien sûr ils ont dit des choses
anormales
[Musique]
désaveu ni comme celui ci on en a vu
dans tous les cieux du monde depuis 30
ans des milliers de rapports des
enquêtes se sont accumulés grâce à cette
masse de renseignements on peut
désormais envisager une étude
scientifique du phénomène ovni ce court
documentaire expose la dernière
découverte en date sur le comportement
intelligent de ces mystérieuses engins
elle a pour auteur de chercheurs
dijonnais charles garreau et raymond
lavier pour en suivre le déroulement
il faut revenir en arrière au 7 octobre
1954 à poncer sur lignon un petit
village proche des sources de la seine
madame fourneret alors que s'est il
passé le 7 octobre 1954
bon bah c'était le soir il faisait déjà
un peu sombre j'allais fermer les volets
et puis j'ai vu cette boule un peu
lumineuse jaune orange au dessus là
entre l'arbre et puis le toit puis
j'avais l'impression que ça venait
sûrement parce que ça grossit c'est ça
aussi c'est de plus en plus
alors j'ai tout laissé ouvert et j'ai
pris le bébé
je partis chavanne derrière quand on est
rentré au bout d'une heure et demie peu
près des côtes les hommes sont revenus
du village on est allé voir tout ça dans
le prix on a vu les traces comme cela
ici par là et que ressembler cette place
elle avait à peu près à mettre deux ans
oui et puis peut-être 50 cm de large
bien alors tous les bords du trou
s'était creusée par en dessous
et bien alors là l'endroit où que ce qui
est plus d'herbe s'est éparpillé tout le
tour à peu près sur une dizaine de
mètres de l'endroit
alors toutes les modes de terre vous
était au tour oui l herbe est resté
longtemps sans pousser où nous voulons
au moins quatre keller mené par pousser
là debout l'observation vous avez fait
était la première est fait dans la
région ici le nom il y avait les voisins
enfin aux pays voisins me suis même
genex z'avez vu à l'enjeu aussi
longtemps à voir vous même jour trois
jours ou 3 jours 3 jours à bord
maintenant j'ai envie de me trouver là
c'était la forme d'un cylindre et puis
le fils bouyer qui revenait dans le
chemin en huile a vu décoller lui donc
le soir vous l'avez voulu arriver est
arrivé
je ne garde son du pays qui rêvait a vu
leur vol
cet engin longtemps après que vous
l'avez aperçu vous même bien au moins
une heure on vit comme une heure ou une
heure et demie ses traces sin est
relevée à poncer on les retrouvera 13
ans plus tard le 21 avril 1967 en
amérique dans l'état de virginie
une extraordinaire ressemblance un
calque presque parfait
pensée fut la première my insoupçonnées
d'affilée qu'irriter tordre sa trame sur
la france entière mais qui n'apparaîtra
que 20 ans plus tard grâce à
l'accumulation des témoignages
recueillis entre temps la seconde my de
cette trame ce fut marliens près de
genlis à quelques kilomètres de la base
de dijon longvic
nous sommes le 12 mai 1967
[Musique]
marc exactement la télé telles vous
versez y avait comme des départs croyez
qu'ils savaient faire un effort pour
l'appareil qui était la pousse voilà on
a préféré le site tmz a soulevé en l'air
c'est pour ça elle rend parler des
soucoupes alors à penser que c'était un
coup bas la terre était comment la comme
c'était un petit peu il avait chauffé
quoi envoyer et moi j'ai eu l'appui on
n'a pas de conséquence soit sous la
direction du capitaine thepenier la
gendarmerie procède à une enquête
extrêmement minutieuses un hélicoptère
prend des photos verticale qui montre
bien l'empreinte en étoile matérialiser
à la chaux des croquis sont faits les
trous d'ancrage du système
d'atterrissage sont dessinés et coopté
par le rapport est terminée on
s'aperçoit qu'il correspond exactement à
celui qui a été établie en 1965 par les
gendarmes de digne dans les basses alpes
lors de l'atterrissage de valensole
ainsi cette similitude parfaite entre
les trous de marliens et de valensole un
an plus tard le 21 juin 1968 s'est brisé
en morvan il est environ 11h 30
le temps était couvert j'étais avec deux
camarades qui passait vers moi et que
les ricains il ya une univers lab en
direction nord nord est né ce parti qui
nous paraît vraiment bizarre les qui
attire est vraiment notre vue quoi si
c'était si cette chose qui est vraiment
insolite
alors on la fixe et on a fixé cette
lueur et environs au bout de deux
minutes
l'adieu à diminuer progressivement et au
même endroit
nous avons aperçu un objet enfin
objets qui semblaient un engin
quelconque d'une une forme et est
vraiment rien connu quoi qu'on ne
pourrait pas du tout par exemple
identifier avec une voiture ou en avion
ou toute chose comme ça ne soit bon et
le l'engin avait l'air de planer un peu
avant de se poser à terre le jeune marc
joly lui voyait même mieux que nous ils
nous disaient qu'il y avait une surface
de soug était un peu un peu noir alors
que le dessus et elle a un blanc un
blanc vraiment immaculé et alors moi ça
m'a toujours intéressé au bout de
quelques minutes de son parti moi je
suis toujours resté mais tout en
piochant les pommes de terre je t'ai
tout même à coup d'oeil d'abord sur
l'engin
au bout d'une vingtaine de minutes j'ai
constaté qu'il avait disparu et j'ai
toujours 6es et quelques minutes après
il s'est produit à flash comme un flash
photographiquement fin d'une intensifs
et intensité assez forte n'est ce pas
rouge et je me suis dit ben l'engin a
disparu alors monsieur michaud vous avez
fini par localiser cet endroit où nous
sommes actuellement
oui nous sommes ici le lieu
d'atterrissage nous avons trouvé une
bille qui était pdi au pied du piton
laborde qui avait certainement refusé d
y ont indépendamment des deux qui ont
jamais été retrouvé les deux buts me
berton on avait remarqué aussi que
principalement là bas vers le bois les
limaces était d'une couleur assez brune
alors qu'ici dans notre région elles
sont plutôt rose et pia le rouge mais
enfin pas brune est alors j'en avais
récupérer enfin une dizaine qui avait
envoyé aux professionnels lautier et la
paix d'allah il y avait quand même une
évaluation aussi de ces deux cpu enfin
on appelle déchets plus commandé 10
voici enfin
le nom moi je parie scientifique et moi
même à la suite de cet incident j'ai
vachement arrivée la maison ma femme m'a
dit mais qu'est ce que tu as dans les
yeux j'avais des yeux toulouges et cjd
bombages issus des rayons vins de
langeac ont aperçu la barre et j'ai eu
des brûlures dans l'épiné dorsale
pendant un mois qu'ils prenaient
toujours de cette irradiation brazès est
l'élément déterminant car en étudiant
quelques années plus tard les
atterrissages qui se sont produits en
côte d'or et en reportant ceux de poncer
marliens et braz et sur une carte aux
200 millièmes
raymond aviez découvre que marc liens et
braz et sont tous deux disent temps de
43 km 202 penser et que deux plus les
lignes marliens poncet et braz et poncé
sont perpendiculaires
c'est le point de départ d'une étude qui
va porter sur les quelques 200
atterrissage signalés en france depuis
le premier d'entre eux près de rouen en
juillet 1947 première opération reporter
tous ces atterrissages sur cartes aux
200 millièmes avec la plus grande
précision possible en faisant appel au
rapport de la gendarmerie seconde
opération reporter ses points sur la
carte au millionième en projection
coniques de l'hygiène puis en établir un
calque
enfin à partir du triangle braz et poncé
marliens crasse et un quadrillage de 4
cm 32 deux côtés on voit de suite qu'un
pourcentage élevé l'atterrissage se
situe sur ces couloirs dont la largeur
réelle au sol peut être estimé à 500
mètres phénomène particulièrement
remarquables en bourgogne franche comté
une nouvelle étape dans cette voie de
recherche allait être franchie en
comparant cette trame aux travaux des
chercheurs néo-zélandais en étudiant les
observations dans cette partie du monde
le capitaine bruce katy avait constaté
qu'elle se situait sur un quadrillage de
33 milles marins qui l'avait baptisé
harmonique 33 et qui correspond à un
carré de 61 km 116 de côté or en
comparant cette trame à la trame lavier
on découvre que la superposition et
parfaite que le premier quadrillage des
autres que des diagonales d'harmoniques
33 la superposition des deux trames
amène une autre constatation bon nombre
d atterrissage qui ne se trouvait pas
sur les diagonales se situe sur
monique 33 près de 80% au total
pourcentage qui a augmenté depuis deux
ans 6h38 atterrissage signalé 33 ans qu
lieu sur ce quadrillage soit près de 90
%
d'où la possibilité d'une nouvelle étape
dans la proche du phénomène ovni la mise
en place d'un réseau de détecteurs sur
les couloirs qui paraissent les plus
fréquentés c'est ce que prévoit le
groupe géraud de besançon qui achève la
mise au point d'une véritable station de
repérage vous avez un appareil
perfectionner ici c'est une station
lorsque une station qui est en cours
d'élaboration qui comporte au point de
vue détection des systèmes magnétique
différent ici qui donneront déjà une
heure une idée de l'orientation de ce
champ magnétique perturbateur de de
l'intensité à ça on a associé une
détection des infrasons parce qu'on a
constaté aussi que dans certains cas les
ovnis et générait des infrasons face à
ses puissants
ce qui donne une sorte de bourdonnement
c'est à la limite de des sons audibles
alors donc au point de vue capteurs nasa
on a une liaison qui se fait par un
câble jusqu'à la station alors sur la
station elle-même on aura ici des
voyants qui correspondront aux alarmes
des différents capteurs on aura une
alarme sonore bien sûr des interrupteurs
de commandes
ici on a une base de temps à quartz qui
donne une bonne précision pour
l'indication horaire des phénomènes
ici on aura un fréquencemètre qui
permettra de mesurer la fréquence des
perturbations magnétiques ou infrasons
ainsi peu à peu des pièces nouvelles
sont versés au dossier des mystérieux
homme
la question de leur existence ne se pose
plus un double point d'interrogation
subsiste encore passionnant et
inquiétant tout à la fois double
vient-il
et pourquoi vient-il
[Musique]
jean pierre
six ans a tenu de nombreux emplois
temporaires avant de vendre des
vêtements sur les marchés de la région
de pontoise salomon des 25 ans d'origine
sénégalaise en france depuis cinq ans
comptable et agent commercial de
formation il préfère gagner sa vie en
travaillant sur les marchés avec ses
amis franck fontaine 19 ans père d'un
garçon de deux mois et demi exerce
depuis plusieurs années le métier de
forain d'abord avec sa mère et ensuite
avec son ami jean pierre prévôt c'était
à cergy pontoise le 26 novembre 1979
il était 4 heures du matin et les trois
amis s'apprêtait à partir pour le marché
de gisors
[Musique]
et on dirait qu'un avion qui se casse la
gueule non tu rigoles toi c'est une
piètre 14 juillet ton truc là maintenant
ah non merde je vais prendre mon
appareil photo
bon je vais voir sur place -
rejoignez-les à bord
déjà j'étais dans la voiture pour
maintenir l'accélérateur au fait qu'il y
avait plus de démarreur sur cette
voiture
est ce à ce moment là où vous avez vu
quelque chose d'étrange mais a perçu
comme une boule qui descendait du ciel
une traînée lumineuse on appelait ça
vous avez décidé de j'ai décidé d'aller
voir ce qui se passait sur place quoi je
suis dit on ne sait jamais s'il ya
quelque chose que je sache peut être
utile peut-être simplement par curiosité
aussi pendant ce temps salomon et jean
pierre jean pierre était remonté
chercher de la marchandise et salle au
moins n'est pas et photos alors l'objet
des parties de sur la droite là bas est
descendue on oublie comme ça savez
quelle forme d'une traînée lumineuse à
peu près à quelle distance de penser que
c'était les autorités ont estimé 3 400
mètres j'ai démarré je suis sorti du
parking est arrivé au niveau de la route
il n'y avait plus rien alors j'ai
continué j'ai décidé de faire demi-tour
l'abord est arrivé à ce niveau là j'ai
aperçu unique et aussi elle met en avant
l' et la voiture à ces arrêtés
la petite boule allers venues se mettre
sous le capot je me suis retrouvé dans
le brouillard
non j'ai essayé de sortir les portières
étaient bloqués
je me suis endormi
à quoi va ressembler l'objet que vous
avez aperçu dans le ciel
c'est à dire que bon vin de temps
c'était blanc opaque et puis bombasse ça
faisait comme un cigare lumineux 1dans
blanc opaque ça faisait comme en cigares
qu'il descendait tout doucement en
direction du champ choo moi ce qui m'a
fait penser une fusée qui adore juillet
c'est qu'à la fin c'était pas très net
ça faisait pas un cigare vraiment une
formes rectilignes
ça c'est très net à l'avant et à la fin
c'était très flou donc effectivement je
ne sais pas moi une boule de feu conquis
décembre est et qui ferait une trame
derrière moi je me suis mis à la fenêtre
pour voir éventuellement s'il restait
des traces de leurs fusées et bon bah là
il y avait plus de trace de la fusée
mais par contre y avait bien des traces
de la voiture sur le côté gauche de la
route et calais monstre est fait
redescendre pour repousser la voiture
que c'est tout ce qu'on avait gagné
jusque là selon moi y avait que ça et
vous c'est le manque est ce que vous
avez vu j'ai vu la voiture de l'autre
côté avec en alo'o pas dit au travers de
la route
j'ai appelé jean pierre en lisant banc
mais ça passe des trucs bizarres
moi je dis ok ok on va là on voit
pousser la voiture on verra bien après
et on est une fois arrivé donc la
bassure sur le terre-plein kohout invite
vision de la route complète là
effectivement j'ai constaté aussi que la
voiture était complètement prise dans
une dans une sphère de brouillard il y
avait trois trop cas je me souviens plus
choix précis là-dessus trop quatre
petites sphères qui tournait tout autour
bon calme ça s'est passé très vite les
spurs sont incorporés à la grosse et à
ce moment là quand tout a été lâchée
plus qu'une seule map
et comme un énorme cigare qui est sorti
sur la gauche de la sphère et qui a fait
office d'aspirateur tout le restant
s'est engouffré dedans et c'est reparti
à une vitesse pas possible et là on
s'est précipité à la voiture c'est là
qu'on a vu que franck avait disparu il
ya un deuxième point c'est quand on ne
sait en bi la con et dès qu'on est
arrivé à la voiture la voiture était
plus sur la gauche de la route mais sur
la droite et en biais entre temps il y
avait un déplacement de la voiture aussi
y avait à hauteur de la portière côté le
chauffeur une petite boule celebros
comme ça
la pâlit
corneau ne fait pas comme une boule
d'une balle de tennis une balle de
tennis - tigres ont quand même
d'apparence une consistance ou mais
toute blanche très lumineuse et semoule
a fait le tour de la voiture et la
portière s'est dans un premier temps
ouverte et refermer et la voiture comme
si quelqu'un la mettait en route deux
fois de suite avant alors que c'est
absolument impossible qu'ils avaient pu
démarrer en du tout bon et après donc
cette boule a fait le tour de la voiture
elle à l'essai à la salle et une fois
que mon clip de coups de contact qui ont
été vite pour essayer de démarrer la
voiture
le la 16c refaire l'autre sens a reçu
une boule qui repartit à une vitesse pas
possible et la voiture était totalement
la voiture n'a absolument pas bougé elle
absolument rien d'anormal dessus aucune
trace de france
absolument aucune trace mme geagea c'est
assez troublant et vous êtes réveillé un
quart d'heure après pour moi vous étiez
vous à cet endroit là la voiture avait
disparu
ah ouais ça faisait huit jours qu'est ce
qu'on pensait en voyant abat sur la voie
je croyais moi qu'on me l'avait volé
tout simplement qu'on aime et qu'on
m'avait mis dans le fossé écriture mais
les frais la voiture alors j'ai décidé
de rentrer chez jean pierre lui annoncer
la nouvelle quoique on n'avait qu'une
marchandise des puits d'eau et le puits
n'était pas là alors je serai chez
salomon et puis mais je cliquais le topo
excellent
je voulais pas y croire puis jours ça
faisait beaucoup et ça les informations
qu'on a eue de sa réapparition
c'est donc ce fameux coup dans un
premier temps c'était un coup de fil
anonyme d'un golf de ma fenêtre j'ai vu
une boule la boule est reparti à la
place il y avait un bonhomme je les ai
suivis des yeux et il est rentré chez
jean-pierre travaux donc c'est franck
fontaine
ça c'est un coup de fil anonyme qui a
été envoyée rtl bon on nous a pris on
nous a fait prendre connaissance de ce
coup de fil et suite à ça bon bah c'est
pas bien compliqué on le comme le gars
partent au boulot il n'y a pas
énormément de gens dans l'immeuble qui
partent au boulot à 88 du matin il a
suffi de monter la garde pendant trois
quatre jours qu'il a fini par rencontrer
et vous a confirmé ce toit il a confirmé
oui et creuser plus exactement mais il a
vu une énorme sphère et qui s'est posé
pas d'après lui ça faisait entre 2 m et
3 m de diamètre qui s'est posé dans le
chant épique est reparti lui je dois
dire que le bas on est sortis où on
n'est pas sorti vial est reparti à la
place y avait un bonhomme
[Musique]